OK.
Let's take a few more calls at six one seven
eight three zero.
Forty seven fifty, starting with our caller
from the seven oh five area code.
Who's calling today from seven 05.
I think that me.
Yes.
Yeah, I'm calling from northern Ontario, Canada.
Great.
I was wondering if you could comment on what
the pandemic.
I've noticed that a lot of especially more
corrupt governments are taking this time to
seize more power than they should.
For example, in Poland and especially in Hungary.
Viktor Orban was given the power to rule by
decree.
And I was wondering if you could comment on
the state of democracy in the U.S., citing
some worrying things, one vote by mail and
gerrymandering that seems that the Republicans
seem to be trying to do.
Absolutely.
So I here in the United States, we have several
layers of of of totalitarian ish tendencies
from the current federal government.
So one of the first red flags was when Corona
virus started.
The Justice Department was asking for essentially
the suspension of habeas corpus, in effect,
where the Justice Department wanted a situation
where if they have people being held pretrial
who normally would have a right to a speedy
trial, which means the charges against you
are presented.
You're given a lawyer a court date that's
relatively expeditious, given a chance to
prepare a defense, etc.
The Trump Justice Department wants that suspended
so that they can just hold people indefinitely
and say, listen, you're not you've not been
sentenced to prison, but you're not getting
bail and you're just going to sit in prison.
And the charges against you aren't moving
forward because courts are operating at diminished
capacity because of coronavirus.
Extremely totalitarian.
Very, very concerning.
We then saw with the protests here in the
United States, Donald Trump's first instinct
when we have protests against police brutality
is to say governors aren't being brutal enough.
I'm going to send in the military in order
to be more brutal and to further repress,
protest, very, very totalitarian.
Donald Trump using so far using Corona virus,
although I wouldn't be surprised to see him
try to use the protests as well to justify.
We shouldn't vote by mail.
Voting by mail leads to fraud.
We shouldn't do it.
It's just a voter suppression tactic.
Trump insists Democrats can only win if they
cheat.
Well, it's clear he thinks he needs to cheat
in order to win or at least suppress the vote.
So it's very, very disturbing what we're seeing
here before all of this started.
The United States in the democracy index was
ranked a flawed democracy, and the state of
democracy here is dramatically declining.
Earlier this week in Georgia, we had huge
voter suppression and strategically left leaning
and nonwhite areas.
I mean, it's it's ugly.
It's very, very ugly.
You know, that's I think that is really concerning.
One thing I was going to ask is, do you think
that with.
I don't really understand it because, you
know, I don't.
I don't live down there.
But I from what I understand, it's with vote
by mail and stuff like that that's in the
care of the state secretary.
Is it the attorney general or the secretary
of state?
There's someone down there, an elected official,
who controls that.
That is, I think, semi independent of the
state legislature.
You know, the secretary when you can do it.
Well, it's independent of the legislature.
But these are elected positions, I believe,
in just about every state, the secretary of
state.
And we've had crazy situations where, like
in 2018, Brian Kemp was secretary of state
in Georgia and he was candidate for governor.
And lo and behold, his overseeing of his own
race for governor led to him becoming governor
in Georgia among widespread allegations of
voter suppression.
Listen, I'm going to have to let you go because
your connection is a bit problematic and it's
coming in a little bit crunchy, but very,
very important issues.
And I'm glad you're paying attention to them.